Antonio Brown and it was so crazy
yesterday Chris and I were trying to
figure out when Antonio Brown was going
to return to the Raiders and I looked
down at my phone and I have a text
message he's returning today and it was
pure coincidence my source was not
watching the show or listening to the
show so as we're talking about Antonio
Browns return we find out he is
returning and he did return he's back
with the Raiders he met with the media
he said that his feet are feeling better
but don't take it from me as you if you
ever would take it from Antonio Brown
here he is from yesterday a lot better
you know working towards 100% you know
it's been a process with your feet
anytime you know you got a lot of
blisters and you know it's hard to
change direction and cut and run and be
able to do what I do naturally I'm a
star under good foot up and away getting
a lot of work so beside look I have a
feeling Chris that the foot well because
we've had speculation about is the foot
issue a distraction from the helmet
issue is the helmet issue a distraction
from the foot issue right now I think
that foot injury plane is gonna land at
precisely the time he has a fully
reconditioned and fully recertified shut
air advantage helmet that is less than
ten years old because his agent Drew
Rosenhaus told me yesterday they have
found a few of them from 2010 they are
still looking for shut air advantage
helmets from 2011 the last year they
were manufactured so if they get this
thing reconditioned and recertified he
can wear it and I guarantee you the feet
will not be fully healed until the
helmet is fully certified for Antonio
Brown to wear it in practices in games
well I mean you're saying you just
talked to Drew Rosenhaus yesterday
you're making me feel like you you know
the answer to that question I mean I'm
not gonna put anything out of the realm
of possibilities in this whole scenario
especially when Antonio Brown is is
leading the charge here so I'm not gonna
say I I don't agree with you but I don't
think you're crazy cuz who knows and
maybe that is that maybe that is the
case I think there are two separate
cases I really do amazing as it is that
you could have two separate cases as
wild as they are
for Antonio Brown but but I got to
imagine I don't think he's I don't know
I don't know what to say I don't think
he's stubborn enough or stupid enough
just to play that game over the helmet I
do think he loves football and wants to
be great at it and he likes practicing
because it helps them be great so I
really think there is a wanting to get
back out there on the field now will it
be easier or he'll feel better about
getting on the field when he puts that
helmet on I agree with you but I don't
know if I agree that it goes hand in
hand I think they're kind of separate
issues well and I don't know how long
it's gonna take to get this helmet
reconditioned and recertified and I'm
sure they're moving as quickly as they
can
I'm just there is no reason for him and
I can I'm trying to put myself in his
shoes no pun intended on this one right
uh why do you want to go out there and
run around with the helmet that you're
not gonna wear this year why do you want
to put yourself through that if you're
not comfortable in that helmet you're
trying to go out there and practice
full-speed and make up for lost time and
if this thing is uncomfortable if it's
an encumbrance if it's keeping you from
achieving your highest possible level of
performance I don't want to do it until
I have my helmet and I could say at a
very basic level the fact that he filed
the grievance and is essentially stamped
his feet like Veruca Salt until he got
what he wanted and he got what he wanted
why would he practice until he's able to
practice in the helmet that he wants so
I think that plane is gonna land just at
the moment the feet it's all gonna line
up just right and it's all worked out
perfect that's the thing no matter what
Antonio Brown says or does it all works
out for him because he did find a
loophole even though he wasn't
necessarily looking for one one of our
readers was looking for it and found it
for him yeah he found a way to wear the
helmet that he wants to wear and this is
him from yesterday when he went to
Twitter I'm looking for a shut air
advantage adult large helmet that was
manufactured in 2010 or after in
exchange I will trade a sign
practice warn Raiders helmet maybe it's
the one that was you know unauthorized
that was painted by somebody other than
the Raiders supposedly but look he found
a few of them and they're in the process
of getting them ready and it's a strange
story with a strange ending a strange
story deserves a strange ending Chris it
does and it doesn't shock me with
Antonio Brown I mean it's all things
have been strange surrounding him the
the last year or so but you know there
was i meanthere's prick the pictures on
the internet and things of him
practicing with the new helmet in OTAs i
would like to think he's a little
mentally stronger to overcome like okay
I can at least go out there and practice
in a helmet I'm not comfortable with I
would like to think that for the amount
he's being paid for what the Raiders are
expecting to be as a leader but but the
other thing too Mike that all that I'll
echo what you said a little bit you
talked about how you know it's all gonna
work out and everything's gonna be good
in the end anyways cuz he got his helmet
it's also gonna all work out and be good
in the end in the end anyways because
gosh did you watch Hard Knocks last
night I mean he's king of the Raiders I
mean he's king I mean Jon Gruden you saw
it it was like he was missing a child
every day has anybody seen my receiver
oh when my receiver gets here has
anybody seen my receiver I mean so you
know I mean he's got a red-carpet
treatment there in Oakland and Groody
well here's is is allowing that and I
ain't that's there's no problem with
that but yeah I also don't think that's
gonna like put a poker in his butt to go
oh I got a I got to get out there right
now because I'm feeling the pressure
from the organization remember the time
you told me that you were sitting in a
room at the Tampa Bay facility and you
could hear Gruden on the other side of
the wall yeah I'm planning about you
right right I mean look Hard Knocks is
an infomercial I don't mean a disrespect
it just is it's it's it's created and
produced by NFL Films which is the NFL
and the Raiders have final say over what
gets used it's not a reality show
I wanted to see Jon Gruden ranting and
raving privately and he's never gonna
show us that about how we got to this
point why did we do this why did we you
know at some point just to vent the
frustration he's gonna be saying why the
hell did we spend all this money and
trade for this guy if we can't get him
on the field what's the deal with this
helmet why won't he wear a helmet you
know they they dealt with the foot issue
last night because they had to Chris it
would have been embarrassing beyond
embarrassing if they ignored it again
like they ignored it last week even
though they knew what was going on but
what they did if you watch it carefully
they never say that he went into a
cryotherapy chamber without the proper
foot no it's very crafted to not make
him look bad right it's an accident it's
nobody's fault it's not his fault
of course it's his fault but that's not
gonna make its way into Hard Knocks
period and if you watch it yes they they
had to address it but they never really
give you that sense of of uncertainty
and there was all hell breaking loose on
Friday the helmet issue was barely
mentioned even though by the time this
show had to be finished on Tuesday they
knew a lot more about it than what made
its way into the episode I have a
feeling they'll talk more about the
helmet issue next week but it will be
presented in the light most favorable to
Brown it won't make him look bad and it
will it really won't give the audience
what really is going on at Raiders
training camp no no you're exactly right
I mean they're protecting their guy
they've invested in them and and of
course Mayock and Gruden they want to
make it work I mean this is that was the
biggest move of the offseason one of the
biggest moves we've seen in any
offseason really here in recent and
recent history
are you surprised Mike though that
nobody in the media yesterday asked them
about what happened with his feet I mean
I know I texted you and I was kind of
shocked by that but I just thought
somebody would go hey what exactly did
happen with your feet and I feel like we
still haven't addressed that which I'm
kind of shocked that that went by
yesterday without being brought up I
haven't seen the whole press conference
but look here's the reality the people
at that press conference are people who
cover the Raiders all the time and if
you cross a certain line with a guy he's
done and and and there's always that
concern he'll shut it down there and
he'll shut you out potentially or who
hold some sort of a grudge potentially
and that's not directly at Antonio Brown
Bill Belichick gets treated the same way
and I've had back and forth with Tom
Curren of NBC Sports Boston when there
is a clear and obvious issue out there
that needs to be presented to Bill
Belichick and no one in the room is
willing to be the one to ask the
question because then they're the one
that gets the daggers from Bill
Belichick that gets the smart aleck
response and then he's mad at that
person okay otherwise shuts it down for
the rest of the press conference so I'm
not surprised if it wasn't asked because
there's no good way to ask it without
potentially disrupting the whole hey
everything is great Antonio Brown is
back vibe yeah I guess you're right you
know I don't know I mean you know with
Bill Belichick I mean he's going to act
like
anyway so who cares if you ask the
question I mean it's it's gonna in the
next week whatever you're not gonna get
anything out of them so you know you
might as well try but I understand I
understand what you're saying I guess I
probably agree with that theory that's
there's are people that have to be in
that locker room have to deal with him
they want a story when they need a story
and they're kind of tiptoeing around it
to not to not ruffle any feathers so
that makes sense I mean for the same
reason that the Raiders are in this
honeymoon phase with brown the people
covering the Raiders are in that
honeymoon phase as well because the
better the Raiders are the more traffic
their web sites will be the more
interesting their stories become and the
higher profile they have this season I
think I think it's some level everyone
who covers a team deep down wants that
team to be great because their work gets
more notice if the team they cover is
great and I don't think you want to be
part of trying to drag that down and
asking a question like that yesterday
you become part of the problem not part
of the solution I'm not saying it's
right
yeah it's trying to understand it
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports